he had hired a psychiatrist who
diagnosed him
with a whole litany of mental issues but
specifically stated that he was not an
antisocial personality disorder it
wasn't like a sociopath or a psychopath
and the judge
challenged that contention in her
sentencing she was like i don't know if
i believe that she had this phrase that
was like his fraud like a circle has no
end
what have you been researching for the
last few years
um i have been researching why people
scam online and why we fall for it
lots of examples of that to go through i
feel like
yes well this all came about uh because
i was the reporter who broke the fire
festival story
um and for your listeners who don't know
what that is that was
um this luxurious music festival that
was advertised as the party of the
century
it had some of the world's most beloved
models and influencers backing it
a lot of money put into it and when the
ticket holders arrived it was supposed
to be on this beautiful private island
flown there by private jets
with you know luxurious catered food
from celebrity chefs
and when the attendees arrived they
found a gravel pit next to a sandals
resort
that ended up being more luxurious than
the festival itself with instead of
these beautiful hotel rooms it was fema
tents
and ikea furniture um and so i set about
trying to find out
how the organizers um led by billy
mcfarland who was
fire festival ceo how they got away with
it and why it works so well
and i started to realize that it wasn't
just them
these scams are going on in pretty much
every walk of life whether it's in
the tech industry in the media on social
media
even the way that we you know a regular
social media user is presenting
themselves to our friends like we are
all scamming each other
and accepting what it is as reality even
though we know better it's a really
fascinating
psychological profile as well as a
business story it's kind of
just come about as well like most people
didn't aspire to essentially be con
artists you know you'd have the
traveling con artist snakes
snake oil salesmen right going from town
to town and grifting and then they'd get
found out and then they'd go on to the
next town
but you are right there's an element of
this sort of two lives that we lead the
one
the front-facing one that we show on
public social media and then the the
real one that's
going on behind the scenes yeah i don't
think that's
happened really ever before certainly
not at this scale
and i think even the most honest people
are guilty of it to an extent
right like most people are not going to
show the lows of their lives on social
media they're going to put their best
face
forward um and even i'm guilty of that
you know if i'm having a boring day i'm
not putting that on my feet i'm putting
the highlights um and then
presenting that to the public as if
that's every day for me
um so i think it starts on that most
basic level of grift all the way up to
the people who are photoshopping their
faces and bodies
who are getting plastic surgery and
pretending that it's natural
who are you know purchasing uh luxury
good shopping bags on etsy and then
staging photographs as if they have been
doing these incredible shopping trips
there's so much just
not even to scam up the only thing
they're scamming is
our perception of them right there's so
much of it going on
and then all the way up to fake tickets
to a music festival that never existed
talk me through what it was like
breaking that
story you'd done your research and then
you pushed a button
and then all hell descended on earth
yeah so it actually it started a bit
earlier than that because i was you know
i'm a millennial i was part of that
target audience that they were trying to
capture
and you know going to meet bella hadid
wasn't really
something that i was looking to buy but
then i saw a high school classmate of
mine
talking about his artist pass on
instagram and
all the benefits that were going to come
with it and you know the special
food and the the special treats that
come like the artist's part they were
supposed to be this huge party with
kendall jenner that people were doing
so i took a look at it all of a sudden i
was like oh my god am i missing
this big event that everyone's gonna go
to i started to feel the fomo that had
been baked into this marketing campaign
but when i went to look at the website
like it looked like something
someone might have made in like a high
school coding class it was so
low rent and so acronistic compared to
what they were
advertising you know if there was really
all this money behind it you would think
that their
their product would match the marketing
um and so that kind of like tingled that
spidey sense where i was like something
is
not right here and it was all very it
you know you think of the story of
cassandra it seemed so obvious to me
that there was something terribly wrong
here um and there were people who
knew what was going on trying to warn
people on social media
i think people were scared to publicly
speak out about it because they were
afraid of getting sued and getting
blamed for the festival's failure um but
it was all out there in the open
any one of these ticket holders could
have come across it the same way as me
right it didn't require this
incredible investigative ability um
and then it all came crashing down on
social media
as people landed on the island and
started to see what was going on
so um at that point my editors
allowed me to move forward with the
story because even they were like you
know
it's a music festival okay it doesn't
live up to all of its claims that's life
and i was like no it's like way more uh
so finally when
you know the cheese sandwich tweet came
out they were like all right go publish
um and that was kind of like off to the
races from there
because billy mcfarland did not stop
scamming even after he got arrested
uh he was out on bail and he launched a
second set of felonies
also targeting people who wanted to live
that life that they were seeing on
instagram
so he was selling fake tickets to the
met gala and to the victoria's secret
fashion show
and he was targeting the same people it
was the same email list and they
continue to fall for it it is
mind-blowing but if your selection
effect to find your
market was do you want to go to
this product that has these particular
brand values you've already selected for
a very particular group of people
who have a fair bit of money and spend a
lot of time on instagram and probably
are interested in the met gala
and the victoria's secrets fashion show
and
like was it backstage with miley cyrus
when she'd stopped
taylor swift she'd stopped doing
backstages like five years ago
one one of the things that you go
through that i thought was so
interesting in the book
is what billy's got up to
since he went to jail can you detail the
laundry list of
[ __ ] that he's been doing since then
yeah it is i mean this guy
just does not stop unrelenting yeah
uh so after he got busted for the second
set of felonies um
he got i think he got off pretty lightly
he was sentenced to six years
and you said it could have been 75 yes
so i mean often in like the u.s judicial
system they will stack all these charges
so it was very unlikely that he was ever
going to face anything like that
and a lot of the charges end up running
concurrently but six years was still
pretty good i mean during his sentencing
he had hired um a psychiatrist who
diagnosed him
with a whole litany of mental issues uh
but specifically stated that he was not
um an anti-social personality disorder
it wasn't like a sociopath or a
psychopath and the judge
challenged that contention in her
sentencing she was like i don't know if
i believe that
you know she had this phrase that was
like his fraud like a circle has no end
but then granted him a relatively
lenient sentence and so i think
for a normal human being you would feel
very lucky
and maybe reform a bit uh what billy
mcfarland did was smuggle a recording
device into prison
which he was then caught with he had
been initially sentenced
to serve at his time at a prison in
upstate new york which was
great for his family and his girlfriend
because it was not too much of a trip to
visit him
and there were celebrities there you
know donald trump's former fixer and
attorney michael cohen was sentenced
there
uh billy mcfarlane was apparently
scrabble buddies and played basketball
with mike the situation sorrentino
what's he in jail for
he's out now but he was serving time for
tax evasion
and so you know it was
it was like the uh instagram vip list in
prison
until he got busted with a fake pen that
had a usb in it
um and he told the authorities that he
was
so eager to get started on paying his 26
million dollar restitution
that he was going to start uh writing um
a memoir in prison and the proceeds of
which he would give to his victims
and he was unironically going to title
it prometheus god of fire
um the authorities were not impressed by
that explanation
and so he was sent to solitary
confinement which is no joke and
you know we can have our own
conversation about whether that's ever
justified
but after that he was sent to
a new facility in ohio which was you
know a definite step down from where he
was
and also happened to be the nexus of a
covet outbreak that was so bad that the
national guard had to be called in
um and so he tried to get compassionate
release
which was unlikely in the first place
but he was knocked out of contention
because he had this serious infraction
on his record
um and then he decided to launch a
podcast and
the thing that was interesting about the
podcast was that
for once he was no longer the marketer
he was the product
um and he you know he said that he was
giving he had co-owned it and was giving
his
share towards restitution according to
court documents he has not paid any
restitution at all
um but he was put in solitary
confinement for participating
in this podcast and his partner on the
podcast um
i'm blanking on their name now i think
it's like notorious llc
something like that they run um a series
of hype houses in la like they are the
billy mcfarland
not in the scammer way but in the
business sense of
influencers um in their market and so
when billy was put into solitary you
know they weren't campaigning for him to
get out
they were bragging about their
engagement and how well the new york
times story about it was doing and how
the podcast had shot up above joe rogan
and you know was more popular than
kanye so it was an interesting role
reversal because for the first time
billy was the influencer he wasn't the
guy
working the influencer and so i think he
recently got out of
solitary again he had caught covet in
prison
how did he do the podcast was that what
you needed the pen for
uh no so he was going to dictate his
memoirs i believe the podcast was just
recorded over
a prison phone so he was on
jordan harbinger's show billy was on the
jordan harbinger show
calling in from and sure enough at the
start of it it's like this is a call
from the united states correction
press 3 to reverse charges um so i knew
he'd been guesting but i didn't know
that he'd managed to
i mean fair play fair play to for doing
up so
i think it might have been in
coordination with him like jordan was
the host
of this podcast and then they actually
repurposed that footage for the abc
special um with whoopi goldberg i forgot
the name of it but so now he's you know
he's the product finally for the first
time
so that wasn't allowed doing a podcast
from prison is also not allowed so he
got into solitary again for that
yeah the the specifics of that are a
little hazy i know other
other inmates have done prison podcasts
with no problem i'm not sure
what exactly the justification for it
was just that that's the fact
i mean solitary confinement is no joke
and especially in the time of covet a
lot of this stuff
stopped being funny um but it is
remarkable that he
has continued to get in trouble and he's
just
somehow unable to kind of stop i firmly
believe that once he's out of prison he
will launch
something new and i think people will go
along with it
the thing i've had this conversation so
many times with people and i've finally
got the
exact person that i want to have it with
and that's you who produced the
emmy nominated fire festival documentary
on netflix which everybody that is
listening to will have watched because
it was phenomenal
um what i realized upon watching
that documentary is that we as a society
celebrate success so much that we don't
actually mind
how people get to success if
two different versions of this universe
had existed the first one where billy
mcfarland was a prick and did all of
this nasty stuff and
con people and was forcing models to get
into the water when they didn't want to
and kind of playing this playboy
lifestyle i'm doing a lot of just grimy
stuff
and the fire festival didn't work and in
another version of the universe
all the same stuff happened before but
the fire festival
hadn't been a total [ __ ] show it had
been
let's say it was it was acceptable and
blink 182 didn't pull out and maybe
there was tons of problems but there
wasn't
so many that it was a big deal in that
second version of the universe
billy mcfarland would have been hailed
as a marketing genius
he would have been the golden child this
guy that managed to wrangle
millennials he understood how things
worked he was able to manipulate them
and move them in the way
okay yeah maybe the festival could have
been a bit better but that's operations
we need people that can market and sell
right that's what we're after
and what that told me was that the
means justify the end
in a way that it's like it doesn't
really matter
how you get there as long as it works so
yeah that's something i've thought about
so much since then that the only thing
that billy did wrong was run an event
that didn't work
in the eyes of the public and you know
the other side of that is i
i firmly believe that had they had the
bands go on
that the people who bought tickets would
have played along they would have been
posting like they were having the time
of their life because who wants to admit
that you
spent all this money and aren't enjoying
yourself right they would have found the
right picture they would have edited the
water a little bluer
and i think that speaks to how we all
use social media one thing that really
stuck out to me
in that documentary was uh mark
weinstein who had been
hired as a producer to kind of try and
help save it in the end
was having the worst time of his life
but he would post these beautiful
pictures of the bahamas on his instagram
and all his friends were very
jealous and it was so unreflective of
reality
um but then also i think you raised a
really interesting point and i think
this has long been true but it's more
obvious and evident than ever in social
media
you know nike sells itself as this
like you know they sell themselves as
lifestyle brands and so we kind of
ignore the fact that you know their
stuff was made in sweatshops or that
you know these companies that are you
know supporting different social justice
movements their executive boards don't
reflect the values that they are
preaching on social media
um uber for example created a playbook
they
deliberately broke laws they would come
into cities and like just completely
ignore
any ordinances or any kind of things
that they were supposed to observe
um because what was going to happen like
they would just raise some money until
they got kicked out
and they had a playbook where they would
you know
mobilize their users to then campaign
against the laws that were limiting them
so there's there's they're celebrated
for that um even though they've never
turned a profit
so a lot of it comes down to the way
that these things are marketed and not
what they actually are do you think uber
is a grift
i mean it's a real company but i think
that our
view of it as this you know unicorn
company that is
bringing value is absolutely aggressed i
mean they have destroyed taxi industries
they resolutely refuse to pay their
workers
what they're worth or to provide them
with any kind of benefits like people
are really suffering and if they're
celebrated
as you know this game changing company
but i think they're game changing in a
negative way not a positive way
did you see that just in london now they
lost a lawsuit that says they now need
to treat
their drivers as employees
so they can't just have them as
self-employed agents which was the
workaround they had for tax and paye
and national insurance and all that
other stuff i was not aware of that but
i think that's a very positive
change yeah that was i think that's one
of the reasons why
they're able to be so competitive right
that the other companies have got all of
these burdens like
having to actually properly pay the
staff and having wages
and like holiday pay and things like
that
um yeah what's
juicero i'd never heard of this
until i saw your book um so this was a
startup that uh really capitalized on
this new kind of healthy
lifestyle trend i think that you see
very much online
and juice press and these companies that
was supposed to be a way for you to
easily get fresh pressed juice every day
in your home
and they raised hundreds of millions of
dollars for this and it was hyped as the
next big thing
and then it shut down almost overnight
because a bloomberg
uh reporter discovered that it was
actually easier they
so part of the business was a machine
and then the other part was a
subscription service
with the juice in these bags that you
would put into the machine like an
espresso pod
and it turned out it was actually easier
to open the juice bags yourself with
your hands
than the machine actually was it was
such a waste and such a useless
product um that this video just simply
revealing this
ended the whole company and there's a
lot of that
yeah and this had it gone it wouldn't
have gone public by this stage but was
probably in startup
had some funding was selling a lot of
products
yeah i don't recall the specifics about
how far they got towards an ipo but
i mean you saw the same thing with
wework right and what brought wework
down was the fact that they had to put
down on paper
the actual value of the company and you
know that company was shrouded in this
new age
mysticism i mean it was an office uh
space
releasing company there was nothing
mystical or even technological
about it but because adam newman was so
charismatic and because
he got an investor who was willing to
give any kind of money uh
with um maya's son and i forget the name
of the fund now blanking on it but you
know funded by the saudis there was a
lot of money floating around they were
able to sell it as this global
revolution
um that was worth you know billions of
dollars and then when it came down to it
it really
was not worth very much at all what's
your favorite adam newman story
um you know i think it speaks to
why people invest money with these kinds
of people
there's a very famous anecdote after he
had
obtained office space in the woolworth
building which is an iconic
building in downtown new york um he
brought a couple of his employees
up for like an after hours visit to see
the space
and um i guess there were these like
half empty bottles of beer on the floor
and he told his employees to drink it
and they did
and then he told us you know it was an
unsecured uh
construction space and he told his
employees who were drunk at this point
to go close to the edge and they did
they would have literally followed him
off
the ledge of this building if he had
asked um
for what you know it's really kind of
incredible
the downfall of wework there are some
amazing
youtube documentaries that have been
done anyone that wants to go and check
out more about that i also
did a podcast with i'm blanking on the
the guy's name but an awesome author
that wrote an entire book
about that um one of my favorite stories
from the last few years the biggest
grift or one of the biggest gifts
was theranos and elizabeth holmes can
you
take us through some of your favorite
parts of that story
yeah i mean this is another example
where
investors were in i mean in vcs
especially and especially i think
because they aren't necessarily
investing their own money
they're investing other people's money
and even if they lose money on these
investments they're still making a
percentage
on how much money they're handling right
so they win no matter what um and so
they tend not to invest in the product
or the company they are investing in the
founder
and so elizabeth holmes crafted this
persona you know like mark zuckerberg
she was an ivy league dropout
she um deliberately lowered her voice
and kind of
faked it to have a more mysterious
persona she almost exclusively wore
black turtlenecks because she wanted to
be more like steve jobs
and so these like really professionally
wealthy people
fell for it hook line and sinker right
you had like the walton family that owns
walmart giving her hundreds of millions
you had henry kissinger serving on her
board of directors
um and even the media fell for it there
was like a fairly fawning new yorker
profile of her
before john cariu oh my god
the wall street journal was able to kind
of expose that these blood tests that
she had been touting
never existed nobody had ever seen them
um
and i think it speaks to just how she
once she had one of the right names on
board right once there was a kissinger
or a walton
associated i don't think anyone else did
any due diligence they saw that
oh this person's doing it so i'm gonna
do it and just jumped on the bandwagon
it was almost like um like a
billionaire's fomo
you uh draw an analogy between i think
covid
the tesla stock price and some of the
um personalities that we're talking
about here it kind of goes back to what
we were saying before but
turned up to 11 in silicon valley and
especially in the vc world
these unicorns are chasing after these
billion dollar valuations
it's so sought after that people are
prepared to forgive
all manner of sins in the desperate
attempt to chase these winds
and it's because the ability to generate
cash
has now been completely decoupled from
what the business can actually deliver
to the market and is purely based on
market sentiment
yes and and on you know how much of the
market they can hold themselves
a lot of the valuations of these
companies are not most of them are not
reflections of
you know what their actual income is or
what they're actually doing it's how
much money other people have
put into it um so it's all i mean i've
heard of my language but it's all
[ __ ]
uh and it's you know i this this even
dates back to billy mcfarland um he was
by the time he got to fire festival and
i think one of the reasons he was able
to get people to give him
north of 26 million dollars for this
thing was because he had
a record that looked on its face to
match what you would expect
of someone in that world he had started
um a tech
startup while he was in college called
spling that was intended to be
kind of a google circles uh reddit
hybrid
that went absolutely nowhere um if you
read the book you can you'll hear kind
of my
exploration of how he conned all his
college classmates and you know camp
friends into pretending to be users on
the site just to juice up the numbers
for investors but he walked away with a
couple hundred thousand
just for that and when it shut down
rather than being seen as a failure
he was suddenly viewed as a successful
startup founder because he had gotten
the money
what happens after you get the money
people don't seem to really care about
what is the single thread
or what are the commonalities that you
have found since
researching all of these different
people the adam newman's the elizabeth
holmes the
jar rules um what is it that
you found as the common character traits
between them all
um most of them tend to be incredibly
charismatic and i think it comes down to
marketing ability and i think that
includes the elon musk's and the donald
trumps
as well um how good are they at
marketing
and as consumers i think that we have
started to
collectively accept hype in lieu of the
real thing
right we're taking that marketing and
running with it without ever questioning
um how real any of it really is
what i find really interesting i come
from a nightlife background so i've run
a lot of club nights
over the last 14 years and um
all that we're playing with in my
industry is hype
that's it because you can be a different
promoter to me and you can start a club
night
in the same venue that i run but two
days later
with similar djs or maybe even the same
djs
with similar drinks prices with similar
looking decor with a similar looking
brand
so all that we are competing on are the
intangibles because the tangibles from
the actual product to the experience
the venue's the same the entrance is the
same the staff are the same the drinks
are the same even the glasses you're
drinking them out over the same
so it's all about the intangibles and um
that really
sort of gave me a black pill on um
on hype it's like an early black pill on
it because i saw how vacuous
most of the marketing that was being
done around this stuff is that you can
you can build people up and there are so
many
natural cognitive biases that we all
have that we
all fall for and that's obviously what
all of these different people are
tapping into they're just doing it
on such a huge scale with so many
millions and millions of dollars on the
line
and i think an interesting element of
nightlife too and
granted it's been a year or so since
i've been to a club
but me too um is that it really revolves
around
influencer marketing too right it comes
down to the promoters and
you know what models they can pull in or
what people with social media followings
they can get to advertise it and so it
becomes associated with those faces
as well um and then another thing
that's interesting too is you know i
grew up in new york city which is very
nightlife heavy club heavy and a lot of
places will advertise you know a
celebrity who's stopping by
um and you know realistically speaking
you're not going to meet them they're
going to be in a vip
area separate from the club goers you
know it's not you're not going to the
club with them but it allows you to
pretend on social media that you were
um there's like a lot of i was at the
party
with dot dot dot i was at the party with
50 cent
with ja rule with whoever it might be oh
that actually happened to me once when i
was uh very young
ja rule did a night at this club called
stereo and
you know he's djing for like more high
school kids and that club would probably
want to admit
um but yeah you know i wasn't surprised
to see him pop back up with fire
yeah it is interesting that sort of that
low key flex that people want they want
their status to be legitimized by being
around other people who are also
successful and this is what we're
chasing and so on and so forth
why do you think it is that we're so
compelled by these individuals
i did there's something so
fascinating about an adam newman and
elizabeth holmes and a
billy mcfarland and when i watch the
documentaries
like yours about them i have the same
emotion i can't describe it it's one of
those ones you know we need like a
german word
i need a there'll be a german word for
it um
it's not chardon freud it's not me
taking pleasure at somebody else's
misfortune it's more
disbelief that there are people that can
do that
probably in my less gracious moments as
a bit of admiration
around their capacity to do that
i think god how stupid are these people
but i'm
i'm one of those stupid people that
probably would have at least been
brought in i remember seeing the orange
squares on instagram and thinking oh
that looks interesting i wonder what's
going on there
what do you think it is why are we so
compelled to well
watch these people part of it and i
think you tapped on that a little bit is
that uh
there's this weird element where people
don't tend to feel a lot of sympathy for
victims of fraud i think it's like a
human psychology
that you look at someone who fell for
something and you kind of think well i
would never fall for that
um and there is like you have a
begrudging admiration for the people
that can pull that off i think it's the
same reason that uh
we love watching cult documentaries or
you know reading about things like that
um
you know it's it these people are
incredibly charismatic they are
you know very interesting and fun and
engaging to watch and i think if you are
watching it with that mentality like
i wouldn't fall for that like i would
probably see through that um it becomes
more of like a fun
a fun experience than um you know
watching someone commit a crime which is
really what it is
uh but also you mentioned with the
orange squares you know you can
see the way people react that one of the
most fascinating things about that
campaign to me was not the people that
participated in it
but the influencers who saw it happening
and started posting orange squares
themselves because they didn't want to
be perceived as not being part of it
um and so they actually had a lot of so
they got free
extra influencer clout from the fomo of
influences that [ __ ] jerry hadn't
put on the campaign
yeah and you know i've read this is
actually a real issue for some companies
i think evian
was one of them um where influencers who
want to look like they are working
or being engaged by these blue chip
brands
will post fake advertisements because
they want their followers to perceive
them as being on a certain echelon
of influencers i mean it really is a
wild west out there
that's so crazy because is there
anything that the companies can do can
they say
can they sue an influencer for doing
free advertising for them
i haven't seen that i have seen some
companies go after influencers for not
properly advertising for them i know
uh snapchat and spectacle did that with
one influencer
there's a little bit of that but um you
know there's not much there's not much
recourse
right and uh even for influencers who
aren't labeling things as ads in the us
like the government
should ostensibly have some kind of
way to stop it or enforce the fact that
these are supposed to be
clearly labeled as ads you know uh but
they can't the most they can do is send
a strongly worded letter that an
influencer can promptly ignore
uh so yeah there's there's really not
much anyone can do
didn't you say that kylie jenner tweeted
at some point that she she was using
snapchat less
and they then wiped one billion off
snapchat's valuation the next morning on
the stock market
yeah yeah i mean the kardashians are
their own
insane case study and in watching the
markets they can move and
the perceptions that they can create um
you know
the book also looks at kylie jenner's uh
billionaire status
which according to forbes which bestowed
that status on her
they say that she had actually submitted
fake tax forms to pretend that she was
earning more money than she was
yeah we're talking about the difference
of a couple hundred million but that
perception in the public was so
important to them
um and obviously generates so much money
for them that
they were willing to allegedly you know
scam a magazine
what other jenna kardashian stories did
you look at
um so this isn't in the book but one
that i've been fascinated by
recently is uh what happened with khloe
kardashian
um maybe a week or two ago in which a
very normal
unedited photograph of her was posted on
the internet
and um apparent it's not clear who
posted it they're saying that it was
maybe her grandmother
um however it was this picture got out
and you know they keep a very
and this actually is in the book they
are so protective of their image that
they actually work with
paparazzi agencies to do staged and
edited photos of them so a lot of the
pictures that you'll see of them
are actually prepared on their behalf
they're meant to look candid
but they're very much part of a photo
shoot to
embellish their images um and so when
this
real photo of chloe got sent around um
her attorneys started
issuing cease and desists to instagram
accounts to reddit
uh threads and boards which had the
opposite effect you know we called the
streisand effect of
all of a sudden that's all anyone could
talk about but it was so important
to her that people not know what her
real body looked like
that you know her lawyers would spend
easter weekend doing this i mean it is
kind of incredible
yeah especially given that that's the
accurate representation
i would love to see the way that this is
translated into litigation speak
you represented our client's body
accurately
and that is is against her brand values
like what and also
if it's a grandmother that's such a
grandmother thing to do
yeah um no so they they did it as a
copyright issue as you know they
they unintentionally verified it as real
and by saying that it was their real
photo
um you know they would issue copyright
takedowns on all the social media
platforms
and one funny way that i've seen some
people get around it is by tracing the
photo because they
drawn like a drawing um is
transformative enough that they can't
come after it with a copyright claim
[ __ ] the bed uh what did you learn about
white claw and jewel
um yeah a lot of things that we think
that we like
are really just the results of effective
marketing campaigns um so i started
tracing this with the rise of
aperol spritz which you know is a
beautiful
easily photographed drink um that i
think
you know if you're being honest with
yourself when it comes down to it like
it kind of tastes like a flat capri sun
like it's not that
that not that good but it became the
drink of summer and
everyone was ordering it and restaurants
were pushing it and all of a sudden
you know i felt prey to it and reading
about the marketing campaign
was kind of a wake-up call for me where
i was like i actually don't like this at
all but i
you know i joined up with the crowd i
felt the fomo um
there's a really interesting 1950s
experiment by solomon ash
where he put a bunch of people in a room
and showed them
a bunch of straight lines and they were
asked to pick the line that looked
closest
to the ones on the screen what the
people in the study didn't know
was that there were plants in the
audience who had been instructed to pick
the most
obviously wrong answer and he wanted to
see how many people would go along with
it and
75 of the audience picked the obviously
wrong answer because
because of peer pressure um because
everyone else is doing it
so yeah that's how i ended up drinking
apparel spritzes
and then white claw you know they had
that that was a traditional
aperol was a traditional campaign um
you know they did bus wraps and magazine
advertisements as well as social media
white claw was a purely social media
push right and it blew up you can
actually track the sales
to a viral youtube video that featured
you know a young white frat guy talking
about how there ain't no laws when
you're drinking claws
and the virality of that video pushed
this drink into the public consciousness
i think the
sales of spiked seltzer like went up
like 400 percent or something crazy like
that i don't recall the exact
figure but you saw a like demonstrable
result
from that and now everyone's just
drinking it
it really is incredible what uh what a
marketing campaign can do
i've got so i haven't had a drink for
about a thousand days because i
was taking a break i've got a case of
white claw delivered by their uk
marketing office i've got one in the
kitchen
i [ __ ] you not hey chris you look like
the sort of guy that would enjoy a white
claw i'm like
we're english we don't know whatever
you're referring to whatever brand
values you think you're
responding to my brand values with i
don't know what you're talking about i
just see it in country music
meme pages that i follow but um yeah
well it's the same as
is it mitch lob
michelob yes sorry um i actually don't
know
much about that it just looks the same
you know it's kind of
the whiskey row country music nashville
kind of that whole world and what about
jewel is jewel the same as white claw
because i thought that was i thought
jewel was like the leader in
interchangeable nicotine vaping
while they were they kind of disappeared
almost overnight in the u.s
at least um i believe like between 2019
and 2020
and that company just imploded uh it
turned out they had they've been accused
by former employees of knowingly selling
tainted pods you know the the nicotine
industry is its own
problem um but you know you see these
things go viral like someone
shows it on social media and then you
know 10 more people
go into it um and i don't know
it's a little disconcerting yeah have
you is there a um
are there some companies or some
agencies that are all
pulling the strings are there some are
there a few big players behind the
scenes in terms of ad agencies or are
these
in-house marketing departments in smart
companies
that are just looking out with a good
meme or marketing campaign
i think it's a combination of both um i
was lucky to really get to delve into
everything that happened with the fire
festival
so and that goes down to like the
internal communications that they were
having with their pr firm
42 west who you know have repped people
like rihanna
and really massive stars um so they
really know how the publicity game
is played and to see the way that they
were spinning those things in real time
and to read those communiques was
definitely very eye-opening what was it
like you know like
uh nobody is it it's never like how can
we tell the truth it's like how can we
take a nugget of truth and transform it
into something completely different that
will allow us to maintain plausible
deniability
um and you know there's a lot of emails
in the book that i won't try to
recount here now but in terms of you
know how they were going to make the
public believe
that the models had some input or some
involvement beyond
this commercial that they had been paid
to film or
how to trick the public uh into thinking
that certain artists were involved
there was a whole line of inquiry into
roping kanye west into it
you know they had people working on
christmas day trying to craft these
press releases
so that machine really never stops what
did you learn from mike bloomberg's
presidential campaign
uh well i think the short answer is you
can only buy so much
uh you know that he put hundreds of
millions i think a billion dollars into
a very short-lived campaign that won him
one territory not even a full state
um but it also shows you how much
credibility
you can buy i guess also the the extent
of influencer marketing um because
you have to have people i guess that are
either believe in the brand or are
willing to pretend
they believe in the brand a lot of
people took money from the bloomberg
campaign to act as an influencer
but then were so lackluster in their
presentation that twitter actually
started flagging a lot of them as
bots because people were just so
uninterested
in you know putting personality into
their social media promotion
but he had you know thousands of people
on the payroll whose only job was to
tweet about him
or to you know upload things on
instagram and then they actually
hired uh the company behind [ __ ] jerry
who did the fire festival marketing to
uh
unroll a meme campaign about bloomberg
so for a while you would see
these you know uh i think the format at
the time was like hey it's mike
bloomberg calling and they'd be like
respond you know with something
funny and would be like a screenshot of
their conversation
um and yeah i mean it was
bro it definitely brought him to the
forefront of it and then i think his
performance and the debates kind of
tanked any momentum that might have been
built
uh but even bloomberg himself was kind
of scamming people he had promised all
his employees that no matter what
happened he got a lot of legitimate
political operatives to come on and work
with him as well because he had promised
that whatever happened with his campaign
they would remain employed through the
november elections whether it was
with another candidate or with the
democratic national committee
um and then just didn't do it right he
like fired all of them
and told them that they'd have a special
pipeline to apply but
nothing ever came of it and there's
actually a class loss class action
lawsuit against him now
from his former campaign employees
i would be such a [ __ ]
grifter like that so bad
because i can't i'm not a good enough
liar
i feel far too guilty about doing those
sorts of things
and this is maybe that is
is part of the attraction that we look
at these people and we think oh my god
maybe maybe they are maybe there's a
kernel of truth in there
and if we can just wipe away all of the
muck off billy mcfarland
he must be a genius deep down it can't
all
be griffed it can't all be just lies in
front
because i wouldn't be able to do that
the vast majority of people wouldn't be
able to do that
um so maybe that's maybe that
contributes to it
the other thing is you highlight
something really interesting with the
mike bloomberg affair
when influence is obviously influenced
it ceases to be influential
yeah yeah i think when you when you can
see the wizard
at work behind the curtain that takes
away from the allure of it for sure
um but another thing is like i actually
had an opposite experience to what
you were saying you know there must be
some truth under there
uh the book details kind of my
introduction to
this influencer named danielle bernstein
who goes by the handle we wore what and
she is
immensely popular and i went into that
experience thinking that i knew who she
was because i had followed her on
instagram i knew her brand i felt like i
understood her um and what i found was
so
opposite from the values that she was
peddling on instagram
talk about that yeah how was it um well
you know
she had we had gotten in contact because
she had known the fire festival people
and had declined to participate in it
and i was intrigued
you know what she saw that made her
decide not to do it
um and so she was going to do an
interview with me uh we had set it up
and then she also asked me to appear on
her podcast
and i thought you know why not it's
great research
um so i went and did it and afterwards
we made arrangements to do this
interview
and then when it came time for the
interview she was like actually i'm so
sorry i'm gonna do my own book
i can't help you um and then you know
these scandals with her started to come
out one after another
where she was accused of taking samples
from small
indie brands and then reproducing them
for her very popular clothing line
and it was just this pattern of taking
things and then presenting them as hers
on the internet
and that i think i fell into and i think
a lot of these brands did
and it really made me realize like wow i
was totally duped by that persona
wow so it wasn't that you thought there
was a kernel of truth it's you thought
it was all truth and it turned out to
be mostly lies yes yeah [ __ ]
what does uh on the internet no one
knows you're a fraud mean
to you um i think that it
is easier than ever to present
a version of yourself that has no
reflection in reality
whether that is by changing your image
by
posting about things you know you saw
you've seen a trend i think in the us of
people posting about social justice or
posting
beautiful graphics uh but then not
living that out in their actual lives
offline
um you can create whatever persona you
want uh and you know
the phrase the old new yorker cartoon
was on the internet it was a dog
typing it was on the internet no one
knows you're a dog i really believe
that uh for the most part on the
internet no one knows what you're lying
about or whether it's real
one of my favorite stories in the book
actually is an influencer who wanted to
convince her followers that she had gone
on a vacation to bali and so she went to
an ikea
and took all these like beautiful
photographs on like like in the
ikea setups you know they have those
rooms that they make up
and none of her followers realized she
deliberately left
some of the furniture tags showing in
the pictures
and nobody noticed
the internet i despair at the internet
sometimes that's another thing touching
on the social justice
issue um
it seems to me that a lot of people on
the internet
would rather have
malicious or um
non-believing compliance
than truthful opposition so they would
rather have
somebody make the mouth noises or the
phone signals that say that they're a
part of
whichever movement it may be even if
they don't believe in it
sooner than be neutral
and be truthful with it yeah and i think
part of that goes along with like the
fomo
getting caught up in the trend too and i
think a perfect parallel to
fire um and you know the influencers who
weren't involved
posting the orange square was when you
saw uh
all the influencers start posting black
squares um
and you know brands were getting in on
it and
there was i forget her name now i think
danielle something on instagram who did
like a three-week check-in
or a month later check-in with all the
brands that had posted a black square to
see if any of their marketing materials
featured
models of color or if you know they're
they had anyone on the executive board
of color
and the vast majority had zero change
zero reflection of these values that
they were professing
except for this one performative square
and i think that's the big part of it is
how performative we are online
that's the word over the last year or so
that i've heard
more than any performative communication
and
it's dangerous coming from someone i
told you before we started i was on love
island season one i was the first person
through the doors
and um if you're not careful if you play
a role
you can bury the person that you are
under so many personas that you don't
know who you are anymore
and that's a really dangerous position
to get yourself into because
you don't actually have any opinions
anymore you don't really know what you
think you don't you all that you're
doing is
trying to do the thing that you think
the person that you're talking to wants
you to do
that's how you live your entire life as
this kind of second order removed
version of you
sort of this marionette and you're
pulling the strings from above trying to
get things to work
it's super super dangerous and this is
why
deception online is so much easier
because you can type something in the
words
said in the way there's no nonverbal
communication
there's sim there's no tone there's no
cadence there's no nothing and you have
minutes or hours sometimes to prepare
the response or the statement or the
press release or whatever it might be to
come across in precisely the way that
you want it to
i think a lot of people are quite bad
liars based on my experience
i've had some of some people on this
show here's one for you
how have i not thought that we can talk
about this have you heard of a guy
called brian rose
no who's that he's the founder of london
reel
which is a podcast big podcast been
around for quite a while now um
brian's initial business partner guy
called nick gabriel
has just done a podcast episode now
brian did
a bunch of live streams on youtube with
david ike the conspiracy
theory guy he did those at the start of
the coveted pandemic
and did some phenomenal numbers like
broke broke some records
with it but very quickly got the live
streams taken down by youtube
they said that he was pushing they were
talking about 5g
and you know you can't you don't need to
know anymore as soon as you hear that
no matter how much truth was or was not
in the live stream
at that time there was a lot of
misinformation going around about covid
and youtuber decided to take a pretty
hard-line approach to remove any content
that it thought
uh contravened uh or was giving
misinformation around covert
so then brian decided to start the
freedom
fund freedom platform fund which was
you're going to love this
gabrielle this is so you he starts his
freedom this freedom platform fund which
is him saying
big text centering us because we're
telling the truth they don't want us to
be able to
so he attaches himself as this kind of
like the vanguard
of free speech activists right uh
talking about
i i thought we had a little thing called
freedom of speech
some people decided to remind him dude
you're in london now
we don't have that we don't have the
second amendment
you know the first i'm sorry there's not
there's none of that here um
so he releases this freedom fund he
generates
one hundred thousand two hundred
thousand all the way up to a million
he gets a million in back of funding
just from his fans
and every time he says we're only going
to do 250 000 and then they hit the
target
and he says well now that that one's
done and now we need now we actually
need to be able to use
livestream capability long story short
it turned out
he'd purchased a white paper out of the
box
like dailymotion live
back end so he'd said he was getting
custom built servers
distributed across the blockchain to be
to not be able to be taken down by
anybody
and it was just someone someone's white
white label use it as you wish video
streaming platform
that he'd put a front end on so that
turned out to be bollocks and he got
called out a lot on
youtube for that now he's running for
the mayor of london
and has been for quite a while and
he's going around in this tour bus and
he's doing all of these vlogs
and today i got sent a video of him
doing sadiq
khan who's the current mayor of london
and brian's calling him out and saying
like
you you you're not in i'm i'm everything
and
it's always very he falls over himself
when he's talking as well he's quite
slick when he does interviews but he
obviously
is struggling a little bit with the
politics side so he uploaded a
six minute long live stream of him
hitting a punching bag a couple of days
ago like quite badly as well it didn't
look like
it wasn't floyd mayweather and then this
morning this morning i got sent a video
of him doing
lengths of butterfly stroke and said
sadiq i know that you won't debate me in
person because you're scared
so why don't we have a swimming race and
then he does it and then he does a
length of butterfly
and turns around to the camera and says
like let's go
at the end it is it's such a grift it is
so bad and what we've seen and this is
something
that seems to be a common thread between
all of the people we've spoken about
today
their ability to pivot and change
direction
incredibly quickly like a pinball so
brian was
all about getting the information about
out about covid and he was all about
freedom and free speech and then he was
all about being the mayor of london and
then he was all about psychedelics for a
while and plant medicine and then he was
doing a trial
triathlon and then he's doing this and
then he's doing that and um
yeah this adhd inability to focus on
one track at one time i guess
that's the digital equivalent of the
snake oil salesman going from town to
town
because as they move on from the last
grifty project onto the new one you
actually think oh well maybe
maybe maybe it's changed now or maybe
this is new and this is different and
this is a different grip
um but you you should have a look at
some of the videos about brian you will
adore them i will but you know i have to
say
this i hate to bring it back to donald
trump but this is
literally the donald trump playbook
right he
made he was never a good businessman but
he convinced the world that he was
because he was on the apprentice and
then he
drew people they know how to capitalize
on outrage and they know
how to say what people want to hear and
you know stoke
this um excitement right so whether it
was the birther movement
uh you know accusing barack obama of
having been born in kenya that's kind of
how he made his name
in politics uh you know and the most
recent grift of his right as he left
office he was pushing this idea
that the election had been stolen which
it clearly was not you know there's
no no rational way to say that that
happened
um he started scamming his own followers
he was fundraising off of this lie
saying you know we got to save the us
you know we have to save the government
donate money we'll we'll do the right
thing and that's why
all these people stormed the capital on
january 6th because they truly believed
that donald trump was going to be
alongside them um
you know ushering in this revolution but
what they
didn't know was um as part of this
fundraising effort there was like a very
small box that you had to deliberately
uncheck because it made your donation a
recurring donation
so all of these like die-hard trump
supporters
realized that they were getting billed
weekly or and monthly and it just did
not stop he
bankrupted like a number of his
followers and there's really no
i mean some people are getting refunds
but there's not a lot of recourse for
that because they didn't opt out
um so i see a lot of parallels uh in
those stories
and a lot of us politicians sadly are
following suit you know there's one
woman marjorie taylor green who recently
posted a video of herself doing chin ups
as like a challenge to the liberal
politicians uh it's getting
really absurd yeah i'd heard about that
although i haven't seen it
it's incredible is it her well just her
form i don't think that's how you're
supposed to do
oh dear um yeah it's um
it's so bizarre the cult of personality
now has overtaken
the thing especially in politics right
i'm okay i'm all right with
businessmen have always supposed to be
charismatic front men
for the rock band that is their company
i'm kind of okay with that
politicians are supposed to be
statesmanlike i don't i i want i want
the
the most autistic nerd who understands
everything down to the finals
yes i want the finance minister to live
in
excel or he doesn't he just he goes to
bed with excel he wakes up with xl
that's all i want
and it would appear now because using
things like instagram and and
um snapchat and tick tock for these
fourth wall break views
perspectives into people's lives like
we'll probably know the
president's dog's name like we're not
supposed to know that
that's not supposed to be important and
all of the time
they have they have an instagram account
by the way major and champ
no way well i mean i didn't know that
but that's precisely what i mean so
the guy that's in charge of managing
that
because it will resonate with the
voter base better to have this
personable
that person could have had a job doing
something to actually add some value to
the country
you know doing something that's actually
going to move the economy or
whatever it might be they could do
something that isn't taking photos of
dogs
right and um i'm all for photos of dogs
but not of the president's dogs like
just
they should be they should be left in
there in the basket
um where do you think this goes
rolling it forward is this a snake
that's going to eat its own tail
or is it still going up are we close to
the precipice here
i don't know i mean this is a
continuation what you're saying about
you know how we should pick politicians
reminds me dating back to when the first
presidential debate was televised
between nixon and kennedy
and it said that the turning point in
that is that nixon was very sweaty and
unattractive on tv whereas kennedy was
you know mad and and had a little makeup
on and looked good and that was really
like a deciding factor
in that election i don't i think the the
genie is out of the bottle
in that sense um but as consumers and as
voters maybe we can try and be a little
more critical and aware
of what values we're supporting and
espousing i know
that going into writing this book i
wasn't aware of how
deeply affected by these things um i had
become and i literally wrote a book
about it and i'm still falling for these
things you know i'm going to fall for an
instagram scam i know it
um but i can try and be better about it
and so i think we can all try to be
a little more critical maybe a little
bit more savvy and canny online perhaps
yeah yeah i agree uh if people want to
check out more of your work and keep up
to date where should they go
um you can follow me on twitter at g
bluestone
g underscore bluestone or on instagram
at g bluestone
um and my book is in all major
bookstores it will be linked
in the show notes below as always
gabrielle thank you so much for coming
on
thank you this was a real pleasure i
really enjoyed our discussion
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace